nuru bonjour et merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france à leur première
question quel regard portez vous sur ce
pass sanitaire qui s'apprête à être
largement étendue et bien bonjour tout
d'abord à remercier de me recevoir je
pense que ce pass sanitaires et bien
c'est l'avènement de la note sociale à
la chinoise puisqu'on voit déjà que la
sncf et air france sont en train
d'étudier le moyen de mettre le pass
sanitaires pour les déplacements donc on
approche petit at il un autre sociale
beaucoup interprètent également fait pas
sanitaires comme une obligation
vaccinale déguisé finalement est-ce que
ces restrictions dupas sanitaires sont
un moindre mal donc je pense que en
france il n'y a que des français là où
emmanuel matheron voix des vaccinés et
des non vaccinés moi je vois des
français est aujourd'hui les français
qui ne sont pas vaccinés faut pas
oublier que les français qui ne sont pas
vaccinés ils ne sont pas tous des
antilles l'aps bien au contraire
moi je ne suis pas du tout anti vase par
contre je pense que je veux que mon
consentement soit libre et éclairé libre
nous ne sommes plus puisqu'on va nous
interdire d'aller dans plein d'endroits
et même changer de région face est
incommensurable de bêtises et éclairée
nous ne sommes pas puisque nous n'avons
pas toutes les données sur cette
vaccination qui est encore au stade
expérimental
oui mais justement cette mesure
permettrait aussi aux français de vivre
à nouveau à nouveau confinement on a vu
que les précédentes confinement ont eu
de lourdes répercussions psychologiques
sur la santé des français
alors ça évidemment ils m'en ont une
répercussion mais pourquoi il ya des
confinement parce que le gouvernement
n'est pas capable de gérer correctement
la crise en israël où on a 80 % des gens
qui sont vaccinées on a aujourd'hui
encore 40% de contamination le vaccin ne
protège pas de la cause de la
contamination est des vaccinés sont
toujours contaminés
donc en fait c'est le chien qui se mord
la queue ça va durer a dit à mme et
terna est temps que le pass à lithaire
qui sera mis en route durera lui aussi à
gotham et ternes et j'aimerais installed
c'est que dans le cas qui nous qui nous
concerne du passage hier emmanuel macron
et peser une menace sur la prochaine
élection présidentielle il faut pas
oublier ça justement vous êtes candidate
à la prochaine élection présidentielle
quelle est votre ligne directrice
ma ligne directrice et qu' on ne peut
pas priver de liberté les français on
est dans un pays libre
alors moi de toute façon dès que je
serai élu je rendrai la liberté à tous
les français j'ai fait un listing on mon
site internet des libertés qu'ils nous
ont été utilisés par emmanuel macron je
me suis arrêté à voir parce qu'il est
beaucoup trop
alors j'invite les gens à aller les
consulter parce que c'est inimaginable
ce que la france est devenue en termes
de privation de liberté
est ce que la france est devenue
aujourd'hui en termes de fracture là on
a en fait un résident qui est pyromane
il met le feu
et puis après ils s'étonnent que vous
parler d'un échec de la politique
sanitaire du gouvernement
comment parce que voilà il l'aurait
fallu gérer cette crise sanitaire on
voit que c'est une pointe d me mondiale
que tous les pays traverse finale ans
que l'on est en train de vivre
aujourd'hui
absolument je suis tout à fait d'accord
le premier confinement était pour moi
inévitable tout en sachant quand même
qu'ils étaient au courant bien avant le
dim à 2020 dont il y avait certainement
des mesures à prendre mais on a un vrai
monsieur et madame macron sur les champs
elysées le 10 mars en train de se
promener et nous dire il faut aller dans
lé reste au top à problèmes et le 16 on
ferme la france non le dit c'est parce
que le 16 il fallait aller voter
donc évidemment qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'autres stratégies que le confinement
mais enfin faut pas le dire à voir
depuis un an et demi que les conseillers
des manuels macro n'ont pas trouvé
d'autres stratégies que d'enfermer les
freins
des zones enfin si on approche
contamination au mois d'une prochaine
vague pardon au moins septembre
premièrement on peut se demander si ce
sera la m annonce qu ils morts qu'avait
annoncé le président au mois de décembre
2020 les quatre cent mille morts on les
a pas eues aujourd'hui on nous dit qu'il
ya beaucoup de contamination moi je le
crois tout à fait mais en même temps
tout italie d'hospitalisation baisse
dont il ya quand même une incohérence
j'aimerais qu'on nous communique tous
les chiffres
tous les chiffres de chaque hôpital en
france et qui est hospitalisé à ce qu'il
faut pas oublier quand même qu'il ya 99
5 % des gens ils se sortent de cette
maladie par bonheur par bode donc yaya
des autres médications ya trop de choses
qui nous sont occultés il ya trop de
qualités il faut que le président s'il
veut que des chants espace k pax mais
est bien en tout cas merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
jacqueline moreau je rappelle que vous
êtes hussein est membre du mouvement
gilet jaune est candidate à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 merci